[Music]
[Applause]
they didn't plan that by the way the
ladies of this is us and they're lucky
blue LED quite the red carpets a brigade
as we break down some fierce SAG Awards
fashion dress how many did you try and
did you know this was the one I tried on
a lot but this was the second dress I
tried on I knew it when I saw it hanging
on the rack I just had my dress it's my
favorite line it covers a little bit of
my stomach got out between children and
it matches your honor and it matches it
yeah it's so great I'm you know Khaleesi
z-- warrior shaman or something I just
feel like you can't touch this I think
we tried on maybe two dresses and we
knew it was this one it'll be a secret
about it well it's no secret that I
can't really walk in it but it's nice
how did the stars prepare to walk the
red carpet for Reese it's food this is
my dinner this is how I prepare oh yeah
yeah I had a curb at the deets behind
Holly's ombre gown it took 10 people 100
hours to hand embroider the sequins and
crystals and to color it the 51 year
olds prep included Diet Coke mints and
this updo that reveals her shaved hair
underneath
Kristen Bell instagrammed a shot of her
hair extensions after arriving in a
fuchsia gown the hosts changed into
three different black dresses sparkle
was definitely a trend so were feathers
and capes but as for other fashion
secrets its custom Ralph Lauren it was
originally supposed to be addressed I
like to move and they were so nice to
make some pants for me so I get my
tuxedo dream it was amazing I have this
ginormous bow because why not be a
little extra secret there's usually on
most women's dresses there's like two
layers of zippers you know there's a lot
of tape it's so much tape I am
legitimately sewn into my dress right
now it took multiple hands to get me in
I also expect that when this is done and
we go to grab burgers I'm going to have
to be ripped out of it but if I ate the
burger with the dress on I may not need
any help getting it off her gum
[Music]
you